c'est la première trêve d'ampleur depuis
le début dans l'invasion russe 36 heures
de cessez-le-feu annoncées par Vladimir
Poutine le temps du Noël orthodoxe qui
interviendrait à la demande du
patriarche qui rit une déclaration qui
suscite la méfiance de l'Ukraine qui Ève
dénonce l'hypocrisie de Moscou et la
cluse de chercher à gagner du temps ils
veulent à présent l'utiliser Noël comme
une couverture quoique afin de stopper
l'avancée de nos hommes dans le
don-basse et de les ravitailler en
équipement et munitions et de mobiliser
les troupes plus près de nos positions
qu'est-ce qu'il récolteront tout
simplement une nouvelle hausse de leur
perte totale la communauté
internationale elle aussi se montre
septique face à l'annonce du Kremlin
beaucoup à l'image des États-Unis il
voit une stratégie russe pour rassembler
ses forces
nous pensons qu'il s'agit d'un
stratagème cynique pour que les Russes
puissent utiliser un peu de temps que ce
soit quelques jours ou peu importe la
durée pour se reposer se remettre en
état se regrouper et finalement
réattaquer réattaquer potentiellement
même plus de vengeance encore plus de
brutalité pour Londres cette trêve ne
fera rien pour faire avancer les
perspectives de paix tous s'accordent
ainsi pour dire qu'à fin qu'une paix
durable soit instaurée Vladimir Poutine
doit retirer la totalité de ses forces
du territoire ukrainien Moscou de son
côté affirme être prêt à un dialogue
sérieux avec l'Ukraine à condition
qu'elle accepte les nouvelles réalités
territoriales des conditions
immédiatement rejetées par Kiev